[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: Cirque
Du Soleil's show, Ka,
has been called the
most lavish production
in the history of
Western theater
and one of the most
technologically
advanced shows in the world.
The show features
stunts by performers
that seem to defy gravity
and put everything at risk.
[APPLAUSE]
I mean, watching you,
my jaw was on the floor.
I was holding my breath.
Is there a certain rush that
you get being out there?
FRANCISCO ALEGRIA: We feel
the adrenaline, you know?
When we come to the theater
and when you hear the music
and you see the curtains
open, and you're just ready.
You leave all your personal
[? exploring ?] behind you.
NORIKO TAKAHASHI: People think
my performance is not so hard,
but actually it's very hard.
It's like the bird on
the water, like a swan.
It's very graceful.
But under the water, it's--
It is like that.
FRANCISCO ALEGRIA:
It's just amazing.
There's nothing like it.
NORIKO TAKAHASHI: When
the audience claps,
I feel I have done
something great.
LAURA LING: Do you get
nervous when you're up there?
NORIKO TAKAHASHI: Yes, I'm
always nervous for 11 years.
People think you do the
same thing every day,
but it's different.
GABRYEL NOGUEIRA DA SILVA: I
get butterflies every time I
go through the curtain.
It's almost like I'm looking
to myself from the audience.
It's risky, but
I love what I do.
We love what we do.
LAURA LING: What are the risks?
What's the level of danger
when you're up there?
FRANCISCO ALEGRIA:
It's pretty high.
My brother and I, we are
not attached to any safety
because you have to be free to
be able to do your performance.
Anything could happen
in the blink of an eye.
So you have to prepare
physically, mentally
to do this kind of performance.
LAURA LING: Do
people think you're
crazy that your job is
performing in something
called "The Wheel of Death"?
FRANCISCO ALEGRIA:
I think so, yeah,
because they scream sometimes
when we're doing our routine.
LAURA LING: What you do on
stage has to be so precise.
What is the preparation
process like?
And what is your
ritual to get ready?
GABRYEL NOGUEIRA DA
SILVA: Well I have
many different little rituals.
One of the things I
do is skipping rope.
I do also juggling balls.
I feel like that connects my
brain to my body completely.
DAN HONG LI: I go
to the training
room and doing warm up, my
Tai Chi and then stretching.
And I started breathing,
like at night, go like inhale
and then exhale.
Tai Chi gives me a clear
mind and positive energy.
SABU ALEGRIA: We love playing
football, all the time,
because we are running.
We sweat.
Every morning this
is like in the Wheel.
You're running.
And sometime, you
need to react quick.
GABRYEL NOGUEIRA
DA SILVA: I also
do some of my capoeira moves.
And when there's other people
warming up in the same room
as me, I try to play with them.
So I think that's the
main goal of my ritual
is to be connected to the other
people that are around me,
you know, so we can deliver
the final results together.
LAURA LING: So it seems
that for you, it's
preparation,
preparation, preparation,
preparation every chance you
get before you go up on stage.
You're going through
your routine.
NORIKO TAKAHASHI:
Yes, I knew that.
I can't just go.
If I can trust myself, I
feel more free on the stage
and it makes my
performance better.
DAN HONG LI: When
I do my makeup, I
just totally, completely,
like, relax and focus.
I think it's very important.
FRANCISCO ALEGRIA:
When the curtains open
and you hear the music and you
feel the people, you're ready.
You know, just automatically.
SABU ALEGRIA: You
hear everything.
You go.
FRANCISCO ALEGRIA:
You are just focusing
on what you are going to do.
LAURA LING: Isn't it hard
to leave your stresses
at the door?
How do you do that?
DAN HONG LI: When
you come on, then you
have to look forget everything.
LAURA LING: Because you've
got spears thrown at you.
DAN HONG LI: Yes, spears--
[LAUGHTHER]
LAURA LING: What do you
love most about what you do?
GABRYEL NOGUEIRA DA
SILVA: Just the freedom
that you have on stage
expressing yourself.
It's doing what you love most.
FRANCISCO ALEGRIA: We
love the performance
because it makes you feel
special when you're up there
and when you hear the people.
That's what is
beautiful about it.
[INAUDIBLE] You
love what you do.
GABRYEL NOGUEIRA DA SILVA:
It's like challenging your body
to its max, you know, to see
how far you can go with this.
SABU ALEGRIA: I think
Cirque is familia.
I like the circus all my life.
Sometimes my wife says,
you need to stop now.
You know, I can't.
I can't.
I think Cirque is my life.
LAURA LING: Be sure to
watch this next episode,
as President Obama's
former speech
writer talks about his rituals
for writing under pressure.
DAVID LITT: We would
write speeches knowing
that there are people whose
full-time job is to pick apart
every single word
the President says,
and, sometimes, just to
take things out of context.
And that can be
incredibly intimidating.
LAURA LING: Thanks for
watching, and please
be sure to subscribe
to Seeker Stories
to see new videos every week.